If you recall.
We said that.
the random variable
by definition is a function.
the random variable by definition the function
I will give you shortly the mathematical definition and then
I will clarify it's a mathematical function that Maps.
the sample space
to
other probability space
what do I mean?
so
big X is what is used to
represent?
Any random variable?
And sometimes they use uppercase letters like
uppercase y uppercase Z, but it's always going to be an
uppercase letter when you see the uppercase letter in statistics. You
know that you're looking at a random variable.
contained within the random variable are
individual
experiments
an experiment is like flipping a
coin.
or tossing a dice
or opening a box
of chocolates
If you often five boxes, those individual
boxes are called experiments. If you flip a coin
five times, you've done five experiments and so on.
So this small X's?
Oops, the small the small X's.
correspond to individual experiments
So you flip the coin once here you flip the coin another time
here and so on and so on.
This is what we call the sample space.
Right a sample space is the thing
that contains all of your experiments.
So the random variable will map the sample space.
to the probability space
And what you're looking at in the second?
Row is the probability corresponding to this particular
experiment. So this experiment has
a as a
probability of five. Okay, think about if you
want to use percentage you can say this is a has
a 5% probability. This one has a 10%
probably 35% probably and so on.
And of course if you remember when you add them all up they add
up to 1.
Right because a probability the word probability
refers to a number a number that is between 0
and 1 it doesn't go beyond one and it doesn't go
under zero. It's not it's never Less Than Zero.
So that's what the random variable is. Again. It's a
function. It's called a variable but
mathematically speaking. It's a function that Maps the sample
space.
these sample space
right to a probability space